mix those two together
pump
okay this one is really stressing me out
this pharmacist is showing people how to
mix Afrin nasal spray into a whole
bottle of retinal eye serum and apply it
to your eyes first off when you mix
products together you run the risk of
messing up the preservative systems
water-based skin care products and
medications have preservative systems in
them to keep harmful bacteria and mold
under control there's a lot of tweaking
to get this right formulas fail
preservative testing all the time so
this is risky especially for eye
products eyes are really prone to
infections people have gone blind when
eye products aren't preserved properly
there's a whole section on the FDA
website on top of that oxymetazoline and
retinol are both really unstable so
mixing is going to make both of them
break down faster and this Murad eye
cream is 135 dollars in Australia
stressed